I don't know what it tastes like when
it's become Jesus what kind of things
there was a big situation
this feels although I'm eating this
[Music]
there was one no Mathon where basically
it was like my lag year between like
college my internship and like grad
school and somehow it seems like when
you have nothing to drink I was on
fasting is the easier but it's actually
the quite opposite being sort of in a
routine and doing your daily life it's a
lot easier to fast and so I was really
struggling fasting during this time my
sister also huddled high gear so one
number on we just basically would sleep
all day which is like not the point
and then we would bake our fast and then
until then we watch Criminal Minds I
know
so wartime then we'd eat and then we do
it all over again and that was my number
line for an entire month in like nine
seasons and there was one particular
episode that there was a big situation
and we're like this feels off this is
not something we should be watching it
was a really scary episode people were
feeding women to pigs in this episode
that's not my proudest Madonn but it
isn't it in this okay one Ramadan I was
in the awkward position of deciding
whether to break my fast with an
unconsecrated communion host I went to a
Catholic High School for all the non
Catholics out there during Mass
Catholics take communion
it's a host a wafer and some wine the
priests like whisper a prayer over the
hosts turn it into Jesus his body and
they turned the wine into his blood so I
wasn't trying to convert but I really
wanted to know what that wafer tasted
like and everyone knew it everyone knew
the Muslim wanted to know what the wafer
tasted like the Ramadan my junior year
this nun decides to make my dreams come
true she breaks into the school
communion stash she runs off with a
wafer just for me she's like here it is
the wafer the wafer of your dreams and
I'm thinking oh my god I'm fasting what
am I gonna do everyone's watching me
I think everyone knows I was fasting I
had like Ramadan
anyway I'm eating it and I don't know
what it tastes like when it's become
Jesus but before it becomes Jesus
it tastes like old paper and I'm
thinking to myself you know what yeah I
should have asked for the wine too you
know if you're gonna go down might as
well go down in flames so a couple of
years ago my best friend and I decided
that for if thou rather than just having
you know like a regular dinner spread we
would host a thing called Pizza Olympics
where we would order pizza from any
place that we could think of have it all
delivered to one location and we would
make all of our guests have a slice of
each pizza and then rank them to
determine which one is the best because
we love science and we love pizza and
these are the kinds of things that make
a lot of sense when you haven't eaten
for 14 hours so we set up our party all
the pizza comes it's all margherita
because it has to be standardized
obviously this is the Olympics we care
about rigor we lay it out and people are
getting in line getting their pizza and
eating it and then there's just this guy
who's a friend of someone else's looking
at the pizza with like kind of a judgey
face and because I'm trying to be
gracious it is the spirit of ramazan I
asked him hey please take a plate please
help yourself and then he tells me that
he doesn't like pizza it's disgusting
and it's kind of fattening and we have
anything else like salad that he could
eat
who eats salad nobody eats salad during
Ramzan the point is fried things and
that's when I learned the real lesson of
Ramzan is that while you know not eating
food and not drinking water can be
challenging not being really shady is
very hard
[Music]
[Music]